una puerta de las que solo se abren a
los vacunados para entrar en locales de
ocio de la ciudad de nueva york ya es
obligatorio haber recibido al menos una
dosis del fármaco contra el hobbit 19
las dos estamos vacunadas siento que es
una forma más segura de venir me siento
bastante bien al respecto
una medida orientada a frenar la
variante delta que está causando un auge
de contagios diarios a escala nacional
equiparable a los niveles de diciembre
cuando apenas había empezado la campaña
de vacunación el rebrote de contagio se
está desencadenando en un repunte de las
hospitalizaciones sobre todo en los
estados con niveles más bajos de
inmunización es el caso de arkansas
donde los médicos se declaran exhaustos
medios es muy frustrante muchos de
nosotros yo incluida sentimos que esto
no debería estar pasando con la vacuna
disponible lo que lo hace muy duro el
personal médico constata la alerta
lanzada por las autoridades la
polarización política de la respuesta a
la pandemia
combatimos la desinformación y nos
peleamos los unos con los otros mientras
deberíamos luchar juntos contra el virus
el virus debería ser el problema y una
de las caras de la polarización es el
gobernador de texas greg abbott el
republicano dio positivo en kobe 19 y
persiguen la justicia a los distritos
tec sanos que siguen la recomendación
federal de exigir el uso de las
mascarillas dentro de las aulas una
medida que también intentó prohibir ron
de santis el también republicano
gobernador de florida el estado más
afectado por la pandemia por lo que a
una semana del inicio de clases todavía
no está claro si los estudiantes deberán
o no usar el tapabocas